one of our sponsors Pepsi has teamed up
with snapchat for a brand new promotion
there's apparently a ton of prizes you
can win just by taking a snap of this
snap cut right here on the label it's
only happening for eight weeks I'm told
one of our interns Eric really threw
himself into the promotion isn't that
right Eric oh man big-time Conan I've
been snapping that snap code all week
and now I have a chance to win like
daily filters and lenses trips Nintendo
switch controllers games that's that's
that's terrific congratulations it's
been a crazy week yeah every day I snap
the snap code I had a chance to enter as
long as it wasn't a fake snap code okay
I'm sorry I don't you mean by a fake
snap code
I guess the real snap codes are only on
participating Pepsi products so all the
other ones I found they don't count wait
how can you tell the difference oh I put
together a video so people don't make
the same mistake that I did fantastic
let's take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
that's real
Dubey
[Music]
are you saying you got a tattoo of the
Pepsi snapcode yeah yeah then I I found
out later it doesn't count for the
promotion you know but no regrets this
is the most fun I've ever had doing
anything and it'll be nice to have a
permanent reminder of my best week ever
and I'm sure you know I'm young but I
think this is as good as it'll ever get
for me hey take it from me this is as
good as it gets
[Applause]
you